i know this might seem like a trivial
detail to start with but i can't help
but be curious what was the conversation
like regarding the change in color of
siri's eyebrows i knew that was coming
the minute you started um well i was the
one who said i'm so sorry but if we are
which hopefully we will get to do many
more seasons i am not going to have any
eyebrows left if they are bleached every
day
of the witcher like they won't be there
anymore and also it requires you
spending however many months walking
around in
you know in the streets
looking like you are
off mars
so um i genuinely had people stop me
when i had the bleached eyebrows being
like where are you from and like they
were so curious
um because i literally looked like a
little alien wandering around so um yeah
it was my choice i said i think we're
done with the bleached eyebrows i think
that was a bad idea so um
so yeah ditch the eyebrows
it makes me no more added than i i mean
just got my usual eyebrows back it makes
me respect the characters look even more
the fact that you stepped up and asked
for that on behalf of yourself and that
they yes what let's create the backstory
that siri you know meets garrett and
goes first thing we need is to dye my
eyebrows mate like let's sort out the
eyebrows that's the back story do you
know what i mean
they went into the they went in and they
got some magical thing and then the boom
the eyebrows came oh i'd believe it
but
how about getting to work with anya this
time around because you get all this
time to get to know each other and grow
close but without ever sharing scenes
together in season one so when you were
finally on set together working together
was there anything about the way that
she approached her work that really
surprised you even though you two knew
each other well
yeah i think i think she um
i was excited because obviously she
nailed season one and so i was really
excited to
um you know get to do scenes with her
and she she definitely gives a lot which
is so nice when you get that because you
know you have something to listen to and
react off and um
but i think she she works quite
differently to me in terms of she really
likes to sort of like
figure out the scene beforehand in terms
of the you know where we're walking and
stuff like that and i'm i'm more of a
like
i i like the spontaneity of it and um
sort of being left to find it in it at
the moment but so it was nice getting to
see it though because you know you can
always take little bits from every actor
and actors will all work so differently
that it's always nice to take little you
know aspects that you like and you've
learnt and things and um yeah she's a
great scene partner so it was so much
fun getting to you know finally act with
her and we'd also built a relationship
off screen beforehand um so uh we sort
of automatically had that kind of trust
with one another which was nice
so you like to kind of go with the flow
she likes to walk everything through
where does henry fall on that spectrum
i mean you know there's always a certain
extent to everyone wants to sort of uh
figure things out to a degree because
there's always stuff there tends to
often be things in you know that you're
you need to discuss um beforehand or you
need to work out changing a line or
something like that so there's always an
element of figuring out it's not
completely like
i'm just walking in you know but um i'd
say geralt um carol i'd say henry is uh
i'd say he's somewhere in between he's
got such the difference with him in in
comparison to me and anya he's he knows
everything about the witcher
so what he brings is like you know if if
there's a if there's a line from the
book that he loves and thinks is
appropriate for the scene he will raise
it and be like can we include this which
is very cool so he's got you know he's
got that that that um that element to
his work which uh you know just that
pure knowledge of the witcher he's just
a witch bible
sounds like an ideal trio a nice balance
of everything there
i will put up the spoiler warning for
this so you could talk about it freely
but you just mentioned that some moments
do require workshopping figuring out a
line or whatnot is there any particular
scene that you really had to kind of
like take your time to work through in
order to get to the end product that we
say absolutely that was um a scene in
episode five between siri and vezimir
er in the lab and um
just there was it goes on such a sort of
like
the emotions of the scenes are just like
goes from every you know she discovers a
massive thing about her past and then
she she's trying to say she wants to be
a witcher and she's trying to convince
him um you know um
to go forward with it and he's telling
her some really horrible you know this
there was so much happening um that we
really did sit down at the table and
chat for a very long time about it um
and um
that was one of my favorite scenes to
shoot because not only do i learn so
much of kim and his way of working um
but also
he just
offers so much and um
and is so real and uh yeah i i loved
getting to do that but it had there was
a big discussion beforehand about it i
was just talking to him about that
moment there's just like a range of
emotional complexity and there are so
many silent moments where i could see
the wheels and both characters heads
turning that i probably could have just
sat there in that scene for an hour
oh thanks thank you so much genuinely
mean it and i
congratulate you from the bottom of my
heart i love the show season two got
even better and i can't wait to see more
thank you so much